thank you
can we explain who Darth is I just if I
drink too much of England's Alter Ego
remember do you remember when you're
Darth so I always usually I wake up in
the morning I'm like hey everybody how's
it going and they're like how dare you
show your face here
and then they started [ __ ] listing
[ __ ] off like this
I mean there wasn't enough hours to do
that like how was I that busy
very busy
Dave England gets drunk to the point
where he becomes his alter ego Darth and
like Dart nothing good happens yeah I
don't do it much because I remember I
remember was it was a 2.5 when Tremaine
was talking about how you know Darth
came out and then the next day they had
you like jumping off of a horse or yeah
yeah so was that because off the horse
so that was so that was way yeah
yeah that was like early in three and
then Dave was like uh like I didn't
drink for the rest of that whole movie
and then for another three years yeah
like three years three years what was it
what was the terrible Darth uh episode
like was it tremaine's wedding or Bam's
wedding oh Bam's wedding and you went
through the hotel just breaking
everything I guess that's what I was
told April is so disappointed the worst
part for me is April's disappointment
where was this in in the fancy hotel
somewhere yeah I mean Philadelphia or
something what what do you drink that
makes you turn into darf uh alcohol of
any sort but you don't know Martin
whiskey or tequila really does the trick
tequila does the trick any alcohol that
gets you can like quickly like like it's
a beer is taking me so long to drink
finally like ah phooey I give up yeah
but that the heart out there you're like
well this is going out easier and easier
and easier wow I don't know yeah nothing
nothing to be proud of that's for sure
but it's made some people laughing
people seem to laugh when they tell the
stories but at the time nobody's
laughing yeah damn it's so [ __ ] good
man he wakes up no idea that anything
was wrong how dare you sure I mean you
must have had mornings like that too
Steve right where you're like yeah
what's your Alter Ego I mean I I had the
time
when uh we were in Russia and I got so
[ __ ] we got so wasted on vodka and
part of the night like was me kissing
Pontius on the dick you don't remember
that no I do remember that and then I
suppose like uh I don't remember
anything maybe later but the next
morning I came out of this little
Bungalow Cottage thing and there's
he looks at me just with disgust
absolute [ __ ] disgust he says
do you know what you did last night and
all of a sudden my heart just [ __ ]
stops and I'm like oh my God I'm about
to hear like I just did something so
[ __ ] terrible oh no oh no what is it
what is it and he goes you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it was so mad at me for kissing the dick
that's so funny dude but you know
yeah
[ __ ] man that's so good I mean were you
a blackout Drinker or did you just do
too much cocaine to where you were just
up yeah yeah I didn't black out too you
ever wake up in jail or like you knew
you were going to jail I thought dude
what a creepy thought I don't think I've
always known I was going to jail
guess what I have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on all of Amazon it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude